the Golden Globes Globes happened last
night and um obviously nobody cares
award shows are stupid Etc but the story
of the night if there is a story is uh
the guy they found to host the show and
now the background here on this is that
nobody wants to host the Golden Globes
anymore you know like 15 years ago it
probably they would not have had this
problem if they want to find someone to
host the Golden Globes I imagine would
have been a a you know a line a mile
long of people in Hollywood who would
love to host the show
but now you know the show is a disaster
it's a ratings disaster nobody cares uh
and so nobody wants to be associated
with it and they asked a bunch of people
they asked Chris Rock and he didn't want
to do it they asked Tina Fay and she
didn't want to do it they asked
everybody until they finally got to this
guy who who name is Joe Koy who is
allegedly a comedian now all you need to
know about Joe Koy is that he came onto
the scene whatever scene he's on I don't
know by appearing on Chelsea Handler
show so that was uh like that's that's
that was his way into the business so he
is on the he's on the Chelsea Handler
comedic tree and that's a tree that has
fallen over in the forest and nobody
heard it and now it's rotting on the
ground and there are worms living inside
it and and like that's the tree that
he's on so needless to say the guy
bombed and um he bombed because he's an
unfunny
hack but specifically because he tried
to pull a Ricky Jes
and kind of roast the
audience but he doesn't have Ricky J's
wit and intelligence which you kind of
need and he also he I think more to the
point he doesn't have Ricky D's actual
willingness to offend these people which
if you're G to get up there and make fun
of them for our Amusement then you have
to be willing to upset them which Ricky
Jes did
infamously um so Joe ky's opening
monologue ended up being the most milk
toast corniest thing
imaginable and um just to give you a
quick taste of it here he is kicking
things off let's watch a little bit of
this welcome to the 81st annual golden
glows I'm your host Joe Koy I loved
Oppenheimer I loved Oppenheimer I just I
just got one complaint needed another
hour I felt like I needed some more
backstory Oppenheimer answered a
lifelong question that's been on my mind
for years yes scientists do get
laid as long as they look like Killian
Murphy I watched Barbie I loved it I
really did love it um I I don't want you
guys to think that I'm a creep but it
was kind of weird being attracted to a
plastic
doll just something about your eyes
Ryan killers of the flower moon is so
great killers of the flower Moon the
cast is here the one thing I learned
about that movie is that white people
stole
everything you guys stole everything not
like 97% you guys stole 100% of
everything you took the land you took
the
oil you took the premise of the
movie what that was your
premise that's hilarious I don't care
it's just that the room is really white
I watch salt burn I want saltburn all
right so that's the basic idea uh it's
it's bad I mean it's you know it's bad
you know you're bombing when he was
getting some polite laughter there but
when you can't get a laugh like a
performative big laugh at the Golden
Globes by making fun of white people if
you can't get
that I mean that should be that should
be a crowd-pleaser like that's something
you you fall back on if you're bombing
and then you go you know what and uh and
and white people am I right they're
terrible they're just the and then you
should you get Applause and laughter and
the whole crowd goes nuts but uh even
that wasn't working for him as much so
that's how bad it it was so bad that it
you watch that and you almost are
longing for these stinging comedic
Brilliance of Trevor Noah like that's
how bad it they might as well have
Hannah Gatsby host next year they might
as well just just open the show with
Hannah
Gatsby rambling for 45 minutes about how
she's sad and obese like that just you
might as well do that at this point it
would at least
be well it wouldn't be any funnier but
it would at least be maybe in a weird
way slightly more interesting but here
here's the here's the the thing that's
the saddest thing about this is that the
people in the audience were obviously
not amused but it's not because he's
unfunny it's because they were actually
offended by these tame corny jokes so
just to show you what watch this moment
where he has like like the tamest joke
imaginable about Taylor Swift and then
look at her reaction watch
as you know we came on after a football
double header uh the big difference
between the Golden Globes and the NFL on
the Golden Globes we have fewer camera
shots of Taylor Swift I swear there just
where to go to here sorry about that and
he apologizes too uh so the joke is not
funny it's tired and lame but uh but
Swift isn't really reacting like it's a
corny joke like she's she's visibly mad
about it she's offended by that joke and
that's why Joe Koy is doing this and not
Ricky J uh these people cannot stand
even the gentlest bit of teasing like
that's how seriously they take
themselves uh the the most cliche hacky
jokes are too much like I bet if you
called Taylor Swift on the phone and she
picked up and you said is your
refrigerator running and she's like uh
yeah I think it is and then you said
well you better go and catch it she
would hang up and cry she would cry over
that it' be it's such a devastating joke
to her that she would cry over that and
um
and that goes to show I guess that that
also shows why nobody wants to host this
thing hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there